goal is to bring
value because it doesn't need my money
it's a small amount but for me if i
invest in this company then i will put
all my efforts in order to support
these specific companies
here in new york on the ground as i
supported hundreds of companies during
the last 10 years
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders and meet my
good friend guy franklin founder and
general partner of israeli map to new
york ventures
guy is the founder and general partner
of israeli map to new york an
interactive platform of the israeli
startups operating in new york the
platform serves as a one-stop shop which
connects the startups to the local
ecosystem in nyc including investors
corporates and business opportunities
the platform franklin created received
several awards and recognitions as this
was something that changed the
conversation about israel and continues
to promote the israeli startup community
in the world guy was named recently in
the 10 most influential israelis in tech
in america
the leading newspaper in israel
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me all the way from
new york city how are you
i'm good here it's morning
in israel afternoon i'm good and thank
you for having me i'm really excited to
have you here guy um you know and first
i want to start with a thank you you
hosted me so kindly a few weeks ago when
you and when you extended an invitation
to to some phenomenal events that you
were hosting in new york with the
community and the ecosystem that you've
built over there supporting the israel
ecosystem in new york and visiting the
nasdaq and the conference with randy
zuckerberg and the president and
president
et cetera so really phenomenal work that
you've been doing but i think that the
journey that you're in uh going from
an accountant to uh now you know
managing an incredible ecosystem and
making amazing investments i think it's
just such an awesome journey so guy
thank you very very much for joining me
here
thank you michael and uh thank you for
the kind the introduction
uh yeah
as you said i relocated to new york uh
10 years ago
to work as an accountant in eui here in
new york after working in iwa in tel
aviv for
seven years in tel aviv i relocated to
new york
um
to be part of the startup group in ui
new york
but then what i realized in my first
year or two here in new york
that there is a
huge uh trend
that started back then
of israeli startups that are relocating
to new york city
and my dad was an ui but in the weekends
i decided to build the platform uh in
order to map the israeli startup
ecosystem in new york
and to have like a simple interactive
map that shows uh dots
uh pins on the map of new york with all
the israeli startups that are operating
in new york
uh i built it i have to ask i have to
stop you already there and ask why
why do that why decide that you're going
to double your workload besides having a
full-time job and working on an
ecosystem that it wasn't very clear yet
that this was going to turn out to be a
huge success
that's a great question
so uh
the main two reasons i did it was first
to show the israeli success to the world
i realized back then there were 56
that's the exact na the exact number 56
israeli startup say wow here in new york
uh today by the way there are over 350
israeli startups in new york and it's
growing amazing
every day i would say even now maybe
another new israeli startup just
landed here in jfk
so basically uh to show these with the
israeli success to the world the
israeli startups here in new york
uh to expose them uh to show that the uh
israeli
ecosystem as roots not only in israel
but also here in new york
that's from one end but the second
reason which is more important was to
connect the entrepreneurs the founders
um the ecosystem the israeli ecosystem
in new york
like seven years ago
uh it was not what it is today that
everyone is connected then there are so
many startups
uh i felt that there were groups of
founders that knew each other but not
everyone
was connected so
um that was another reason and the the
platform i created is you know it's an
online but the activities i did
physically here in new york on the
ground
uh in addition to the online platform
that's what gave the the platform uh uh
it's a validity i would say meaning that
i connected the founders i invited them
um
one of the goals is as you said and give
an example if a founder in the cyber
industry is relocating to new york
uh in order to like you know to say to
not to do all the mistakes that the
founders that relocated while
uh to him uh and did some mistakes they
learned some lessons he can save all
that time
and consult with them and then focus on
the business
i avoided doing some mistakes and then
get connections to
investors potential clients talents
even pr and the different media channels
so the goal was to have like a smooth
landing pad for uh future entrepreneurs
and also to help the existing ones here
in new york
i love it but but the journey doesn't
stop there so you're creating that
you're creating the map and you're
you're now at this epicenter
facilitating the understanding of what
is happening around the new york
community for for israeli startups but
but you don't stop there what do you
learn first just from the work that
you've done up until that point
what what do you learn about the israeli
ecosystem about new york that that is
not very trivial
sort of land about the israeli startup
ecosystem specific in new york and i
will compare it to other
you know
other countries that have also you know
new york is a global place there are
startups from all over the world
but i realized that the israeli
ecosystem and the israeli founders and
not only the founders the executives
also the other employees
they are different from other
communities in terms of uh that they
would like to help each other
really supporting each other even you
know for free for nothing just uh
if there is an entrepreneur that build a
company 10 years ago
he will do
everything he can to support a young
entrepreneur and
i will not say which other other country
but uh there was a funny story because
um there were a few startups from a um
a country in europe
and they wanted me
to reach out to someone who did it very
big from the country here in new york
and when i reached out to him
i asked myself why they don't reach it
why they don't reach him directly why
they ask me to reach
to go out and
talk to him for them and when i talked
with him he told me oh sorry i don't
want to be associated
with my origin and
i i will escape this opportunity and for
me it was crazy to hear that in israel
it's the opposite if i reach out to a
founder that i don't know did an ipo
from an israeli startup
and i will invite him to talk with a
group of
he is where he founders are just looking
of course he will come and he will uh
you know uh even if he will even like
cancel a few meetings on that day and he
will come and he will speak 100
so uh so the israeli startup ecosystem
is very it's unique
and uh i learned that a lot of people
would like to connect and they are
looking uh for uh uh opportunities
um and also i found out that uh ev
almost every israeli that is looking for
a job in new york
is looking at the platform and reaching
out to me when i built it i didn't uh
thought about the the talent side of the
the the jobs i would say
the career opportunities but that's the
i would say almost the number one reason
why people
are going to the to the platform from
junior to even to ceos and executives
that are looking at to see what are the
opportunities
um i found out that investors that are
looking to invest specific in israeli
startups even when they google they see
the platform they reach out to me and
ask for my advice
uh also corporates that are looking for
way to embed new technologies they reach
out to me so it's kind of
i will not say that i built the
ecosystem because it was exist i just
connected it
phenomenal uh
now you don't stop just in the
facilitating the ecosystem and
and embracing it and growing it
but then you're actually going to take
an active role in the financial side of
things and also you know in the actual
tangible partnership with companies
where did this thing come from the
investing in startups and forming groups
to to create positive investment
strategies
yeah so um
that's a great question you have good
you have great questions and
it's good
so uh the i would say that the um
evolution of israel in mexi new york
which started with a platform that i did
uh in addition to my day job in eui or
sosa after the after ey i was the
managing director of social new york
um so in addition to my work
uh in these places
i i built the platform
first i heard the entrepreneurs as i
mentioned
but then over the years what i saw that
the entrepreneurs that i supported them
in so many aspects when they just
started in new york
three years ago four years ago six years
ago now with uh um
they're
you know they expanded
they've they're in the growth stage
some of them are raising a serious a or
serious b funding
and then i realized that the the like
the organic i would say a growth of
israel eventually new york
is not only to support them first in
connect different connections
why not to take it to the next level and
to invest in these companies and
continue to bring them value
in new york and today i would say that
companies
are looking for value and not only for
money
so if even if there is a great there is
a great vc that would like to give the
money now they are looking for the
for the value
and i think that at this point in time i
was in the right point in time here in
new york when i started uh and i decided
to invest in the companies
because there are so many companies so
much capital in the market these days as
you know
and i think that if i uh um suggest
to an entrepreneur that is here in new
york the founder uh to
put a small portion
uh into the serious beer on the series
a1 next to inside partners or next to
other great vcs they'll delete investors
and then i'm reaching out i'm putting
small amounts
uh small amounts i mean you know in a
round of between 20 to 30 million dollar
i put it around between 500k to 1
million
but the goal is to bring
value because it doesn't need my money
it's a small amount but for me if i
invest
in this company then i will put all my
efforts in order to support the these
specific companies
here in new york on the ground as i
supported hundreds of companies during
in the last 10 years so uh for example
i'll give one example it's the company
that i uh pop like a publish that i
invested in it
uh it's a avo
avo is a
fast-growing company i would say
just closed the 25 billion dollar a few
months ago uh 20 like
inside partners with the lead investor
and
i helped
i brought in a group of engine investors
under my umbrella and that's the way by
the way i'm doing it i don't have a vc i
don't have a fund
i have a large network of a
private investors most of them americans
that are based in new york and
to each investments
from this group i'm bringing the most
relevant ones for the investments so for
example they
invested in a scenario they are doing
cyber in health care i brought experts
from the health care
aspect
in avon the same people from the retail
or
real estate world and uh another
investment i made is in anima app which
is in the devops uh vertical
tool
for developers and designers and in that
i brought a relevant group specific for
these investors including
uh if you would like to uh say a few
words about that
and no i i i think that first of all you
know everything that you've been doing
is uh
everything is
doing is phenomenal and about the
companies that you're investing in is
you know they're amazing and i'm very
honored and that you that you
that you offered me to join uh in the
investment group for for an map and i
have to say that the the diligence
process and the presentations and and
the thinking the the thinking process
that that you've led
the series of investors as well as
yourself prior to making the decision uh
does not shy that of any top-notch vc so
it's very impressive that you man you've
managed to both take you know the the
agility
and the of the network that you have and
of the private investor nature but then
still bringing the deep diligence and
the deep understanding
to that to that same phenomenon now now
guy i have to ask you you know looking
back
how long has it been since you moved to
new york
exactly 10 years ago exactly 10 years
ago 10 years ago did was this a part of
the or is this a part of the goal to
you know to become an investor 10 years
later to lead this ecosystem to be a
focal point for israelis in new york
city and make phenomenal syndicates for
some of the top companies was this where
you were trying to head when you move to
new york
completely not you know you will ask
every israel when he is relocating to
new york for how long he is going to be
he will he will say for two three years
yeah so so that was the goal to be ui
two threes and going back to israel
but
and i never imagined that i will do what
i'm doing now and more than that you
know when i built israeli map to new
york it was a platform that was not my
day job after that i was at salsa and
i'm i'm telling you that if someone when
i created this platform would tell me
yeah in a few years from now when i was
in e1 you know 24 7 working on like
crazy with a group that i managed if
someone would tell me now that in a few
years
israeli bacteria will be will be my my
business and would be my you know my
main job i would i would laugh because
it started you know it's but it's what
is nice that it's
it's it's was growing like organically
with me and with the ecosystem and
because it became like the nature fit
so it's exactly like a you know a mirror
of what's going on with the israeli
tech ecosystem here so i didn't push it
too much
i had my my deja vu during the years i
made some adjustments and fine tuning
until the point i mean now and in 20 to
i plan on making
additional investments
uh but the investments are not the only
thing i'm doing with israel and after
new york still in addition to the
investments there is a huge demand
from uh vcs
from different israeli entities from uh
service providers even
uh from uh
companies everyone wants something
in your connections to potential clients
and corporates in the banking world in
financial sector you know insurance
companies and banks
some companies now and by the way the
companies are invested in and some
others i thought that the main challenge
would
would like to they relate to me to help
them in sales you know connections to
potential clients but
all of them the first the first thing
they need and also in addition to others
is talent there is a competition today
on the talent
everyone wastes so much money you see
that in israel as well
i see it in new york it's the same
because uh you know invested in the
companies that we mentioned before and
others the first thing i asked them okay
how can i connect you to clients you
told me
first we need great employees for abc
positions and please help us in debt not
in uh not in the sales
uh of course also in the sales but
uh our talent become a a huge priority
and
by also uh
some other other companies
that are now in conversations in order
to invest in them and i'm we're talking
about the value i can bring them here in
new york
for them as well talent is the first
priority
huge competition
right and uh and i think that
that makes a lot of sense now tell me
you know guy if you're looking towards
the future and the vision the greater
idea of israel in new york how do you
see this community running how do what
do you see happening you know as we're
moving forward and we're getting into a
more globalized world and and and israel
has a stronger presence in new york
yeah so uh
i would say that during the coffee time
um we saw
um there was a few articles i read you
know in the israeli media about the fact
that
uh israeli founders don't need that to
relocate
to the us anymore because they can work
from israel they can grow the company
but i would say that
nothing will replace the physical
presence here in new york for the
companies um
i just i can give you one example of uh
bora air it's an israeli startup based
in new york the founder relocated two
months ago
roi feierberg and they just told me that
if he before you know thought that he
can manage it can do it remotely and
come from time to time
the impact of being here
is dramatically in in his world it's
dramatically
changing the the way the company act you
can he is on the ground you know 24 7.
um what in israel you can do from israel
here everything is like 20 minutes in
the subway from every elite or every uh
contact
so uh
i think that
sometimes it's a you know it's a like i
said i would say a convenient
for some of the funds to say now it's a
different world i can do it from israel
nothing will replace uh to your question
you know the the
the globalization it's there but
you have to be on the ground in order
to succeed and scale uh in your business
there's no doubt about it
guy well i do i'd want to say that we
miss you here in israel so i hope that
we find a balance at some point but but
but i couldn't agree more and i think
that you know me being there myself and
um and experiencing a little bit of what
you showed us from the community you're
building there you can feel the energy
you can feel the energy of the presence
and
and the work that you're doing there and
obviously the track record and the
companies you've invested in and will
invest in
and i definitely hope to continue being
a part of that journey as well so thank
you guy for for everything that you've
done for the community a incredible
journey yourself very inspiring for
anybody who's doing whatever they may be
doing but but leveraging opportunities
being having an open mind seeing what's
happening around creating value but
really truly value because like you're
mentioning it's not that extra million
dollars you're adding to those rounds
which is a lot of money but but but you
know relative to the round
but really it's the value that you bring
which in relative to the check says
that's huge and i think that that's
really awesome so guy thank you very
very much thank you for your time and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you michael for having me and i
hope to see you soon not online but
offline a hundred percent so now bye
[Music]